it's titled tuesday probably my favorite
looking forward to a lovely evening lots
of love
oh lots of love thanks so much
i appreciate that do i play do i play
the dirty england
i can't i can't help myself let's do it
let's try at least one game
pre-move 97 i i can't help myself
let's just pre-move everything
ah they didn't take oh that's
disappointing
now they take
uh i guess i'm gonna have to suffer the
consequences
it's just a bad opening
okay i'll try and make it work though so
i'm down upon
i shouldn't be doing this on my title
tuesday
um i mean the good thing about being
down upon
is having
one extra half open file so i basically
this file and this file to work with
which isn't so relevant right now
i'm going to try and keep some time
advantage
i mean time will probably be like the
main form of compensation
that's a good move
and b5 probably coming
um okay so if takes takes at least i get
the bishop here
and the problem is i i have an isolated
pawn
and knight d4 is coming i can maybe play
this move
so now of my d4 i can take
95 here i don't want to trade pieces
ah there's this move
i think we're gonna probably gonna end
up trading pieces
i mean maybe at some point d4
and what else to do
i can play knight g6
knight c4 maybe knight c4
wait upon was attacked twice i'm losing
another pawn here
it's interesting though because if takes
i have knight b2 the queen takes
[Music]
this is not a good start
i have so many regrets right now
i'm gonna be down two pawns but i have
to think happy thoughts
i have more open files
and now i have more time
oh okay and queens are staying on the
board which is nice
how do i how do i generate things
g5 g5 is probably self-destructive
i'll play 27
[Music]
i just have to avoid trades and keep the
position
as tense and as tricky as possible
that's a good move
that doesn't work hello eric just one
more month till i get that juicy juicy
one-year badge
meal thanks neil
appreciate that
i'm in big trouble here
uh
it's so hard not to get forked maybe
queen here
bishop d3 coming
ah bishop d3 my only save moves are here
and then i get forked
gotta roll with the punches
that's a good move too i'm losing
another pawn
and my time
i mean the one thing
is now i'm expected to lose
so all the pressure is on my opponent
that's a good move
save the queen
so i'm threatening f6 actually let's tie
down to defending the bishop
i could move this move
okay stay focused
ah
please play this please
it's a little bit tricky
i don't think i'm losing anything more
or am i i'm down so much material right
now
queen defends a thing
maybe winning the spawn
wow i'm only down two pawns
oh these rooks are gonna come in
wait my rooks are activating kind of
um
okay that's what i wanted so my king
gets in front
if coffee is pronounced coffer why
doesn't it make you cough
one frozen tea
star
it's still meat it's still me i survived
that
it's i oh it's a miracle
everyone you can use your stalemate
emote i don't know how i survived that
also i kind of bluffed i bluffed
here because if takes it's not stalemate
because king here
wow i don't know i didn't deserve to
to draw that
but sometimes good things happen to bad
people